[Music]
skeeball is my life I met my wife
playing skee-ball skee-ball has had a
material impact on my life and I want to
share that with others and this space
will be a conduit for that joie Mucha is
a three-time skee-ball national champion
and the owner of joie de ket an arcade
rental repair and events company that he
started in 2010 building my business
started out as a side project to my day
job I bought at that skee-ball machine
on eBay to practice and then had to
learn how to repair it so the natural
progression was to put it in a bar see
if it could make some recurring revenue
and then use that money to buy another
skee-ball machine in 2014 Mucha
purchased this warehouse in San
Francisco's Mission District as a repair
and storage facility in 2019 he decided
to convert it into an arcade and
restaurant which should have been a
straightforward process since the
property was already zoned for
commercial use but a community activist
incurring nothing more than a six
hundred dollar fee was able to
temporarily scuttle mooches plans
forcing him to spend months rallying
community support and pleading his case
at a public hearing Joey the cat's new
outpost is slated to open in spring of
2021 but the story of how the project
was nearly stopped in what Miuccia
endured in order to prevail underscores
how even the most benign land-use
changes in San Francisco can be hampered
by red tape it's a root cause of the
city's housing crisis and jeopardizes
San Francisco's competitiveness over the
long term Joey the cat should be renamed
Joey the liar
this isn't within 500 feet of an
elementary school we're talking about
proximity to schools we don't need other
people walking by that and seeing these
negative toxic images I'm not converting
this to a private event space only for
corporates I'm converting this to a
public space that can be used by all in
a perfect world if there was no red tape
we would have been open six months ago
muchas troubles started when Kevin Ortiz
a local activist affiliated with the
anti gentrification group Cultural
Action Network filed an application for
discretionary review a process through
which any member of the public can ask
the San Francisco Planning Commission to
review an application for a building
neither ortiz nor cultural Action
Network responded to our interview
requests even though these reviews are
supposed to be used only under
exceptional and extraordinary
circumstances they've become a regular
part of the city's land use process for
example the owner of a falafel
restaurant was able to delay the opening
of a competitor by claiming that the
neighborhood already had enough falafel
this homes third floor addition was
blocked on the grounds that it wasn't
sufficiently Victorian the conversion of
a laundromat to an apartment building
has been delayed for over five years due
in part to its casting a shadow on an
already shaded school yard so far in
2019 the Planning Commission publicly
heard 91 requests for discretionary
review because every building permit in
the city is subject to this process
it adds enormous cost to construction
exacerbating the city's severe housing
shortage
Miuccia prevailed by devoting enormous
time to winning over community support
which otherwise would have gone into
running his business I've basically
become a politician which I don't want
to become and I don't want that for
anyone I've watched a bunch of Planning
Commission hearings and research to kind
of understand the concept because small
business owners shouldn't be flung into
this process and expected to be perfect
at this when the activists are going to
these we almost weekly I've gotten a
profile and all the different planning
commissioners I know their names and I
know kind of what they vote for and
against my team and I went and garnered
as much support as we could from the
community and we've worked with
architects and had to figure out how to
make this space work for both what I
want it to be and what is legally
permitted and make good business sense
out of it and finding that triangulation
is incredibly complex and challenging
and has been very burdensome process for
a small business owner
Miuccia went door-to-door in the mission
asking for help from his neighbors at
the hearing more than twice as many
supporters his opponents came out to
speak joy the cat is fun for both adults
and children and more importantly it is
kept clean and it is a safe environment
which is more than I can say for some of
the parks and our neighborhood political
connections also came into play
Miuccia received a letter of support
from California State Treasurer Fiona MA
who once held a fundraiser at Joey's
arcade on a principled level I think
it's so hard for a small business owner
to be successful in this city and when
you start to layer on red tape for these
hurdles and roadblocks that come out of
personal interests or community
interests that don't necessarily align
with the business it makes it very
difficult and I think it's something
that should be changed at a policy level